hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
characterizing viruses from deadly
pathogens to the workhorses of gene
therapy
i'm ross verkiel of beckmann culture
life sciences and i'll be moderating
today's live event
today's educational webinar is brought
to you by lab roots and sponsored by
beckmann culture life sciences
a global leader in centrifugation and
life science instrumentation
for more information on beckman coulter
please visit beckman.com
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
i encourage you to participate by
submitting questions for our speaker at
any time
to do so simply type in the ask the
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
in the tabs across the top of the page
you'll find information on related
applications
upcoming and on-demand webinars as well
as links to the cell culture heroes page
you just may be our next cell culture
hero also please notice you can share
this webinar
on your personal social media just click
on the social sharing tab to let your
friends and colleagues know about
today's live event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
with great pleasure i now present
today's speaker my friend colleague and
biophysical characterization expert
akash bhattacharya of beckmann coulter
life sciences
for akash's complete bio please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
akash you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you ross for that really nice
introduction and
thank you everyone in the audience who
signed up to attend
our webinar this webinar is the first
auc webinar from beckman closer life
sciences in 2020
and the topic of this webinar is
characterizing viruses
from deadly pathogens to the workhorses
of gene therapy
and we'll be covering a number of
different topics ranging from
the biophysics of characterization of
certain components of viruses
all the way down to looking at empty
soil partial capsules
in the gene therapy context
before we get started of course i have
to show you this slide which has
certain legal disclaimers and statements
and then we can go on to the roadmap for
today's talk
so first we're going to talk about the
biological characterization of
viruses and discuss uh in some detail
what that might actually mean
and then we will go on to three
different case studies
the first case study involves the
application of sedimentation velocity
auc
to study the starscope two main protease
this is of course an extremely important
system at this point in time
the second case study looks at the
application
of sedimentation equilibrium auc
experiments
to study the behavior of viral fusion
proteins
also a very important uh subject in the
public health context
and finally the third case study looked
at
um examples where scientists used aav
along with sorry used auc
along with several other analytical
tools
to optimize the production process
in a gene therapy workflow and then we
will summarize
what we've discussed okay so
characterization of viruses so you know
you
although that old statement that if
you're talking about something and it
looks like it doesn't it
quacks like a duck it must be a dust
right
however you're not talking about dust
you're talking about virus particles
and if we are looking at for example
an hiv virus it looks like an hiv virus
quacks like an hiv virus it must be an
hiv body
right that does raise the question
what do we mean when we take cracks like
an hiv pilot
so this of course is the um the crux
of the question what does it really mean
to characterize a virus
now if you are characterizing a virus
one of the things which you might be
doing is looking at functional acids in
other words is the virus infecting
the organism that is supposed to be
impacting and you do that by
the function of assays like plus
counting and so on and so forth
the other is you look at the components
of the virus now a virus is essentially
some form
of genetic material dna or rna
and it's usually associated with some
form of protein coat
so you would look at the genetic
material the genome
using some form of nucleic acid
amplification perhaps with these vcr
experiments
and you look at the proteins which come
along with it
by using perhaps um using analyzer
using something as simple as an sds page
and then it goes beyond functional
and component characterization you
talked about characterizing interactions
and now you're actually looking at
something more interesting you're
perhaps thinking of
how do uh protein protein interactions
between the virus and
the host cell occur or how do protein
nucleic acid interactions occur
and that's an entirely different type of
question to ask
and requires a whole battery of
instruments
to answer such kind of questions and
kind of the region where we first want
to focus our efforts
we want to talk about interaction
protein protein interactions
for the most part now i'm going to jump
ahead a couple of slides very
quick okay the technique that we are
going to be using
in all of the case studies that we are
going to talk about today
is analytical ultrasonication or auc
now analytical ultra centrifugation is
a solution phase native space
hydrodynamic technique which looks
at the sedimentation of analyzed
particles
under a very high centrifugal force
speed
and tracks the movement of these
particles as
they move down the sample sector in an
auc
cell and interprets that movement
in order to get the size the mask
and the shape of the analyze particles
and you'll recognize immediately that if
you have the size
the mask the shape of the analyzed
particles in an aud experiment
you basically have the essential
elements to find out almost everything
you need to know about the equilibrium
thermodynamics of this system in other
words if you have a question
about the oligomerization state of the
analytes you can answer it
if you have a question about the binding
constant between say protein a and
protein d
you'll also be able to answer that so
auc really is an extremely versatile
tool which allows you to answer all
kinds of biophysical questions
in this context
which now brings us to case study number
one
and that is the starscope 2 main
protease
so as we all know carscope 2 is
the close organism behind the kovite 19
pandemic
which we are in the middle of right now
and therefore a tremendous amount of
scientific
expertise has been devoted to finding
out everything that we possibly can
about this causative organism and
one of those studies is the basis for
our case study today this is the paper
published a few months ago in
the journal science and this paper
talked about the crystal structure of
sarkozy main protease
and uh it used structural studies
as well as biophysical studies including
to
discuss the development of uh
inhibitors of sarcolepsy
so the importance of this is of course
it's vital because um the name
protease of the pasco 2 virus
is an essential protein in the viral
life cycle
so in other words if you find a
mechanism
a drug candidate perhaps which inhibits
the action
of this protein then you may be on your
way
to actually finding a treatment for
coget 19.
and of course in the context of
understanding how in inhibitory um
the candidates for the main protease of
cytoskeleton might work
you actually have to understand the
protein itself that is to say you have
to understand
the main protease of carscope to on a
structural
level as much as you can and you also
have to understand its interactions
from the biophysics perspective as much
as you can you have to in other words
answer questions like is this a monomer
or is this a dimer and uh is there for
example the propensity for
a dimer to form during the life cycle of
the bias
so um summarizing what we've talked
about so far
the main viral protease uh frequently
called ccl pro or m
pro co2 is a very attractive drug target
this is a protein essential to viral
replication in other words if you
throw a spanner in the works and prevent
this protein from properly
functioning then you might be able to
develop a drug candidate against cobit
19.
then and co-workers use sedimentation
velocity aoc to characterize
the memorization behavior of this
protein
and this of course is an essential step
in developing viable cell cancers
so the protein by itself a couple of
crystal structures have been
solved and published and
as you can see uh these structures are
shown out here
the protein by itself is a 33.8 kilogram
protein it exists in
the dynamic form and a couple of views
of
the dimer are shown here so
zhang and co-workers they carried out
sedimentation velocity experiments
where they uh ran an increasing
compensation
of the karskov domain protease which is
uh m pro
and they uh ask the question does this
sediment as a monomer or does this
element as a dimer
and what they found was that the
monomers which uh as you can see
sediment says 2.9
meters gradually converts into the dimer
with sediments at 4.5 bedbugs as you
ramp the concentration up
in this they uh try the
series of concentrations going from
about point two three micromolar all the
way to eighteen point one micromolar
and when they went to eighteen point one
micromolar they really had almost
i would say like ninety percent of this
is actually a dimer
and that's really very interesting
because it tells us that
this protein does in fact dimerize so
what can we do with this what
they did using this experiment series is
that
they uh then went ahead and asked the
question that
okay so it dimerizes and we actually go
ahead and find a binding constant for
this
and they did in fact so the
binding constant that they were able to
find for this system
turns out to be about 2.4 micromolars
and this is derived from the same data
set that you saw in the previous slide
turns out that this binding constant is
actually kind of similar
to the binding constants of the
main protease originating from
the first sars cove virus which was
discovered
about a decade and so ago so the two
uh viral proteases from these two um
different but related viral viruses
actually behave kind of similarly
so what does this mean going forward in
terms of drug development
asp was one of several techniques which
the authors
used in the study that they published
so what they were trying to do was used
a bunch of
um in silico and in vitro techniques
in conjunction to this to design
better inhibitors of this drug now if
you're trying to inhibit
a drug i'm sorry if you're trying to
inhibit
a protein in this case the main protease
of carscope 2
you're going to be running some kind of
kinetic studies
and some kind of pharmacokinetic study
to actually figure out whether
your drug candidate is doing what is
supposed to that is is it actually
inhibiting the target protein
in order to do that you need to know how
much target protein you have
in the assay that you're using for
finding out whether this drug is
effective or not
now that is fine you think you know what
uh
uh how much protein you have going in
but if the protein
is itself capable of
time arising and as it turns out the
dimeric
form of this protein is the
catalytically active
form then you need to know
how much of the protein is actually
categorically active
in your drug assay and how much of it is
in access
because that really tells you whether
your
drug is inhibiting or whether it is not
and
again this is something where zhang and
coworkers used auc to find out
that if they were doing assays at one
micromolar
they would have 21 percent of the
protein catalytically active
and if they were doing acid with two
micromolars they would have about 38
percent
of the protein catalytically active and
using that information they tested the
different drugs that they were
looking at and they found a drug
candidate which inhibited
the recombinant south coast ii main
protease
with an ic50 of about 0.67
then they used that information further
and they
did some in vivo studies as well where
they found that this candidate is
promising
and they are moving forward further and
hopefully
using this as a lead candidate
for developing an actual inhibitor so
this case study
in summary its importance really tells
you
that analytical ultra centrifugation is
an extremely powerful tool
which can be used for characterizing
components
of viruses and specifically it can be
used
for addressing questions which are
related
to the discovery of novel drugs
against these biology
with that being said let's move on
to the second case study and the second
case study is all about viral fusion
proteins
and it uses a slightly different
experimental technique
so let's put the context of the second
case study together
this is an experiment carried out using
sedimentation equilibrium
and we'll talk about that in just a
moment but first the biological context
vital fusion is an essential
part of the viral life cycle for
say something like the various influenza
viral strains out there therefore
studying the process of vital fusion is
really important
because if we know what are the
different viral proteins which are
involved in the process
of fusing a virus to the host cell
membrane
then again we might be able to develop
a therapeutic intervention which can
prevent that fusion process
and therefore actually prevent viral
fusion
and therefore prevent violent infection
and that's exactly what uh
motivated the authors behind this study
in which
web and co-workers they looked at a
number of
different viral systems and
asked the question of what's really
happening
to the transmembrane domain of the viral
fusion protein
now let's break that question down and
see what it really means
and i just told you membrane fusion
which we have shown over here
in this cartoon is this process where
the
virus interacts with the host cell
membrane fuses with it and then
dispenses the contents of the virus
inside the host cell and again
understanding this process is the key to
blocking this process and therefore
blocking vital infection itself
and this process occurs via the
interactions of various viral proteins
with host cell proteins on the cell
membrane surface
which are called receptors and
specifically
the system that we are going to be
talking about
is the vital fusion protein
and even more specifically it starts
membrane domain
so viral fusion proteins are this
extremely complex arrangement of a
protein structure
which sticks out from the viral membrane
surface itself but there's also
a part of that protein which is embedded
inside the viral membrane and that is
the part
which is shown to the right of the
figure
between the red dots over here
and the blue dots over here and this
system as a matter of fact
is actually derived from the influenza
viral fusion protein so
structural information about what's
happening
to that part of the viral fusion protein
which is speaking outside of the viral
membrane
is has been investigated by many
scientists and there is quite a bit of
information out there
structural information about what's
happening
to trans membrane domain which is shown
now in this
bracket that's not very widely available
and that is the exact
system which web and co-workers looked
at in this study
so the technique that they use is called
sedimentation equilibrium
now sedimentation equilibrium
experiments
are a different type of aec experiment
as compared to sedimentation velocity
they are called equilibrium experiments
because they are run at somewhat slower
speed
and when you run an aec experiment at
slower speeds
then you may have the situation where
after a while
the sample analyte
actually forms an exponential
distribution
inside the sample cell that is to say as
you gradually go outwards in radius
you have more and more samples piling up
and the distribution curve is completely
exponential
and the thing is that this situation
occurs because the centrifugal force
has been balanced out by the diffusion
and therefore the system is actually in
an equilibrium
and taken as a hole the sample is not
sedimenting continuously towards the
bottom of the tube
in other words you're not having a
pellet gradually accumulate at the
bottom of the tube
and the curves that you see over here
this curve can be fitted with the
appropriate constraints
to provide an extremely accurate value
of the analyzed molecular weight
therefore if you have an analyte which
is a
a monomer of a protein it's going to be
fitted to a particular value if you have
an analyte
which is completely climatic
then it's going to be fitted to a
different valley if you have a mix
of these two then you will be able to
find out
using a number of different experiments
where you essentially run
a titration physique you'll be able to
find out the
um the equilibrium
between the monomer and the primer in
great detail
so what webb and co-workers did was
they made these kinetic fusion proteins
where the transmembrane domain or tm
shown in light blue belongs to the
specific
vinyl system that they were looking at
for instance they looked at rabies they
looked at influenza
they even looked at ebola but
the attached sort of surface exposed
domain
that was a universal domain
which they use for all of these climatic
systems
so the idea behind that is that
any interaction that they saw in
their equilibrium asp experiments would
therefore be
attributed only to the trans membrane
domain
because that is different between these
different kinematic proteins
and not to the surface exposed domain
and the different systems that they
studied included ebola rabies influenza
and as a stars go fusion protein as well
and this is just an example of
one of the various data sets that they
looked at so
what they found here called influenza
is that their equilibrium experiments
demonstrated
that there's a one into three or one
into three
to six equilibrium for transmembrane
domain
depending on the species and the ph
so the importance of this is
significant what this study tells you
is that the transmembrane domain
of the viral fusion protein is actually
involved in an allosteric action
in and of itself and it is perhaps the
primarization
of these transmembrane domains which
should be targeted
by a therapeutic intervention
so to summarize this case study
understanding the biophysics of viral
entry is really important in designing
a drug intervention which can deflect
this process
and therefore prevent viral infections
in this paper web and co-workers
they found that the transmembrane
domains
of viral fusion proteins of the
different systems that they studied
which included rabies ebola influenza
and sarco1 all of these systems display
some form of velocity interactions and
a sort of a governing model for these
appears to be the formation of primers
and sometimes
hexamers depending on ph
this is really interesting and exciting
because it tells us that if you can
design a drug which can prevent this
primer
formation then that drug might be a good
candidate to prevent such vital
infections
okay which brings us to case study
number three which is all about gene
therapy
now gene therapy and specifically
study of adeno associated viruses
is something in which auc
is widely used so let's talk about this
system
and embed the biological concept
the case study itself comes from this
paper published
a couple of years ago by joshi and
co-workers
in methods and clinical development
so the context for this
is this
gene therapy is a
extremely active area of research
and the number of clinical trials which
are currently in play
has increased from uh
something which was barely
one or two a couple of decades ago to
the hundreds today and
in these clinical trials
the use of adeno associated virus or aav
as the gene therapy vector of choice
is also becoming more and more
widespread
every year so
let's talk about um gene therapy and
the use of spiral vectors and sort of
at high level encapsulate what this is
all about
the idea over here is that you have
some kind of a therapeutic transgene
which you have incorporated
into a viral vector which is
a sort of a carrier now the viral vector
therefore has
some viral dna and also has
some of the therapeutic clause genes
inside of
the viable dna now when the viral vector
is introduced to the target cell
then the viral vector enters the target
cell
and eventually the the viral vector
capsid breaks down
releasing the gene
inside of it to the host cell
now the genes inside the viral vectors
of course include the therapeutic
transgene and that therapeutic
sound gene is used by the host cells
to make some kind of protein which then
treats
the disease condition so really
in a very hand waving sort of a way it's
the equivalent of that old saying that
you give a man a fish he eats for an
afternoon
you teach a man to fish he eats for a
lifetime
the idea behind gene therapy being that
you don't just
provide a small molecule drug
to the patient you actually train the
patient's
body to defeat the disease conditions
and the mechanism we use to claim the
patient's body to do so
is the therapeutic sun gene and the
mechanism by which you
deliver the therapeutic transgene to the
patient's
cells which need it is the viral vector
so adreno associated virus or aag
is one of the most popular viral vectors
for
gene therapy in current use and
to give you a very high level uh
introduction to what aav is
is a 4.7 kilobase single-stranded
dna genome and the capsid
is made up of three proteins vp1
dp2 and bp3 in a 1 into 1 is to 10 ratio
with about 60 monomers
the entire thing has a mass of about 3.7
mega
so existing production methods of aav
yield something like 10 to the 13 viral
genomes per liter
a phase 3 trial can require
a lot more viral genome and
therefore the question
is that how do we improve disease
of viral vector production for gene
therapy
so in this case study yoshi and
co-workers
they they use something called the fed
batch
bioreactor system now the essential idea
behind the fed batch bioreactor system
is really quite simple you try to
increase the density of
the manufacturing cell system now
whether that's
uh htk 293 or whether it's some kind of
ss9 virus system uh
the basic idea is that you increase the
density of
this manufacturing cell system by
spiking
the growth culture with nutrients at
various standpoints
and in doing so you end up with
a much larger output of
virus particles now that's great however
just having a large output of virus
particles
is of course not enough you need to know
whether those virus particles
are actually bioactive in other words
are they
actually going to be useful in the gene
therapy context
and that is really the question for
which auc was employed
by yoshi and co-workers and that's what
we're going to be talking about
so we are back again to that original
question of it
looks like an hiv virus waxed like an
hiv virus so it must be an hiv pilot
we're of course not talking about an hiv
virus we're talking about an aav
so that earlier question now
breaks down to another component where
it
looks like we're now going to focus on
this part
of the sentence so what do we mean when
you
really say it looks like looks like
would typically be interpreted in terms
of whole particle structural land now
this could be electron microscopy
this could be some technique focused on
particle sizing some technique focused
on mass determination
or even shape determination now electron
microscopy is of course an image
basically the idea being that you
image the virus particles and you try to
find out as much as you can
by interpreting those images
what if you had a way to find
out everything you need to know about
particle size
its mass and shape using one experiment
which was in the native space
remember electron microscopy is not and
in the solution phase and even more
importantly
when you're characterizing not just any
old virus
but specifically a viral vector then the
all important
question which you have to ask with
particle sizing and mass is the question
of
loading efficiency and what do we mean
by that
what we mean is that the virus particles
that you have studied
are they in fact carrying the complete
genome that they should be or are they
carrying a partial genome or arteries of
antibiotics
so the optima aec is
the preferred technique in viral vector
quality control and this is
an example of a data set where an optima
aep
experiment a sedimentation velocity
experiment
was used to distinguish between empty
capsids shown here on the left most
sedimenting
at 60-ish 65-ish redwoods
and partial capsules which are about
75-ish
sweaters and full capsules which are
shared above 90s peppers and
the separation as you can see is down
to baseline in other words there is no
overlap
between empties and partials and full
capsules
and the importance of this is
something that cannot be overstated i
mean the fda
has status that viral particles that
do not contain the therapeutic gene are
unlikely to have telephoto activity
however
these particles themselves might produce
an adverse
allergic response and this is really
important when you're doing
a gene therapy drug trial you really
want to treat the patient with as many
therapeutically bioactive particles than
you can as you can
and don't want to give the patient empty
virus gases
so this is where auc comes in and this
is where auc shines
so let's look at what abc does in this
specific phase study
the optimal aec data can be used to
identify the percentage of empty
capsules
and this is a useful metric for av
quality control so in this case study
uh the authors yoshi and co-workers
they used the ss9 cell culture system
and they grew cells in the normal or low
density bioreactors
purified everything analyze the genome
by qpcr and then
ask the question how many of my virus
particles
are actually full and then they did the
same
with the high density of fed batch
bioreactors shown in the bottom panel
and the fed back bioreactor of course is
distinguished by the nuclear spikes
which are added to increase the
overall manufacturing cell density again
purify the
viral vectors when they did the qpcr
analysis they found that there's a
six-fold increase
in viral genome concentration and when
they did
the particle analysis by auc
they found that
the viral particles being produced
have largely the same mp pulse ratio
as the normal or low density bioreactor
system
so what are they talking about really
this is what their traces look like
the 67s species that they found
is uh the empty viral capsule
and the 98 or 95s species that they
found
was the full viral capsule so
the first thing that they found was that
the anti-capsules are between 62 to 67 s
and this is the range of radiation that
you get
going from low density or conventional
growth to a high density of head bash
growth
they also found that the fully loaded
capsids
sediments between 93 and 98 s
and finally they found that the
percentage
of capsules which actually have the full
genome load
is about 74 percent for
low density and about 80 percent for the
high density fed batch
so this is a really good result because
what it tells them
is that the use of high density or fed
batch growth process
while it gives you more virus particles
it does not give you more empty virus
particles it gives you
largely the same kind of virus particles
mp4 ratio that you would
get with the conventional process which
means that there is really no downside
to a high density growth
and a high density growth might be the
best way to
get the um total amount
of viral vectors that you really need
for a phase speed file
so it's important finally is that abc
helps to optimize aap production
conditions
and to maximize productivity
okay so let's summarize everything that
we spoke about
the optima auc data offers a unique way
to characterize viruses
in the solution native phase either with
whole particles
or looking at the different components
of viruses
in case study one we discussed the use
of sedimentation velocity aec data
to determine the fraction of
catalytically active dimer
for starscope to main protease this
information was used to optimize god's
genetic study
in case study number two we discussed
how sedimentation equilibrium data has
been used
to demonstrate that the transmembrane
domains of viral fusion proteins
such as an influenza or an ebola or a
lady
are implicated in some form of oligomer
organization now this
helps us understand the mechanism of
viral infection much better
and it also tells us which step of viral
infection
might be a useful target for drug based
intervention
and case study number three uh we
discussed how the authors
use the uc data in determining the
fraction of loaded genomes for aav viral
vectors
by a fed batch or high density growth
system
and they compare this to aav produced by
the conventional or low density
roof system what they found that
the high density growth system gives
them largely
the same fraction of loaded particles
and this is very useful in optimizing
growth conditions
to maximize the production of
chiropractors
a few additional resources some of our
previous webinars
are available at this link for more info
also look at this resource that we have
called spin sites
and we have more webinars coming in fall
2020
as well as a mini symposium series with
guest speakers from academic and
industry labs
and i want to thank everyone for your
time and your attention
okay thank you akash for your great
presentation on
uh the in-depth um analysis of these
viruses in their characterization we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar
as a reminder please submit questions by
clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
with the
first question so akash is it better to
do an equilibrium experiment or a
velocity experiment if i'm trying to
find
the kd
well it kind of depends ross if you're
uh so for what it's
worth when you're trying to find the kd
ultimately what you
are going to need is uh you're going to
need to have a binding isotherm and on a
binding isotherm
i mean if you think of what a binding
isotherm graph is like
you've got an increasing concentration
of a titrant on the x-axis
and you have got the fraction bound
on the y-axis now how are you looking at
the fraction bound that's the question
right if you're looking at the
appearance
of a particular species which you know
as this is the bound species where
proteins a and b have come together to
give you a system a b
then you can just see um you can just
track
the appearance of the sound species via
a velocity experiment
and as you titrate an increasing amount
of a b
or a you generate your binding isotherm
and get your kd
on the other hand the rationale for
using an equilibrium experiment would be
that you very specifically want to
identify
your bound species the a b species
by molecular weight and nothing else
and this is because equilibrium
experiments are really very good
at determining molecular weight uh in
fact
they're probably the best way to
determine molecular weights in an auc
context
so if you want to go that way then you
would track the appearance
of the ab bound species and know very
specifically by its molecular weight
that it is absolutely a b
and it is not for example um ab2
or a2b
and that would allow you to determine
the kd with
great accuracy
okay thank you for the response on on
that the next question we have
is asking a broader level but how many
types of viral vectors are being used
right now for gene therapy
okay so there are quite a few different
options
in that regard so adenovirus is of
course one of the most popular
viral vector systems which are being
used for gene therapy and
adeno-associated virus is also a very
popular system
but apart from that people have also
been running trials with vex
providers vectors and uh
you know other lentivitis vectors as
well and
as far as i know some other systems
including herpes simplex virus have also
been tried
and as a matter of fact uh people have
even tried
uh to just use naked or you know plasmid
dna
without an actual encapsulation vehicle
for
gene therapy as well so number of
different systems are in place for this
great um so we've got a couple questions
coming in it looks like around the
different types of viruses as an add-on
to that so i'll combine a few here
but first part being um what's the
difference between adenovirus and
adeno-associated virus in gene therapy
and as a follow-up to that why is the
dental-associated virus seeming to be
most common and prominent for gene
therapy
okay so i'm going to preface my answer
with the caviar
that you should talk to someone who is
a full-time virologist to get the exact
information that you need
but yeah we can try to point you in the
right direction for some of these
answers
so adenovirus and adreno associated
virus are both
fairly popular vector systems for gene
therapy uh
adenovirus and as you as you can
surmise adeno and adeno associated virus
are actually related in terms of
replication cycles and in terms of
infection cycles
so the reason why one would want to use
addition
is it accommodates fairly uh
large size therapeutic transgenes and
they can affect both replicating as well
as non-replicating cells
and the reason why one would want to
use adeno associated virus is
that aav viruses are
first of their basic they apparently
are not very pathogenic so
um that's an important criterion in
terms of
inducing some kind of allergic response
although that is that is
up to a certain amount of debate and
there's a lot of ongoing research on
that
area um aav viruses can infect
non-dividing cells
as well as dividing cells and um one of
the most important things is that aav
viruses
are capable of integrating into the host
cell
genome at a very specific site on
chromosome number 19
and this is a desired feature
because um it's predictable right i mean
it's not like for instance
a retroviruses which may end up
giving you a random insertion of
metagenesis
and you might not know where that is you
have to
work harder to track it but if you know
that it's going to go to chromosome
number 19.
uh that's one of the big advantages of
aav and of course
there is a small disadvantage to aav and
it
comes from the fact that the av virus is
actually a kind of a small virus
so the uh overall size
of the genome that you can the
therapeutic genome that you can stick
inside it
is actually limited
okay great good response um yeah thank
you
so another question is following up on
something you mentioned
earlier in your presentation where you
were mentioning the
importance of knowing uh empty partial
full ratio and they're just looking for
a little bit more information on why
it's so important to really focus on the
full particles
why it's so important to fully focus on
the full particles right
so uh yeah let's let's talk about this
so when you're um when you're
providing gene therapy treatment to a
patient
then what is it that you're providing i
mean you're providing a therapeutic
transgene
and the therapeutic transgene is
supposed to make certain proteins which
treat the disease condition
right however the therapeutic transgene
is
carried in via a delivery vehicle which
is
at least in or in origin
is a virus so if you're going to be
treating
a patient with a delivery vehicle which
is
a virus so regardless of
how much effort has been put in into
trying to find something which is as
non-pathogenic as possible as the
delivery because
there is always the chance that there
will be some kind of an immune response
so you want to minimize that immune
response
you want to maximize the therapeutic
effect
and you want to minimize the adverse
allergic effect
so therefore you want to deliver
a drug product which is as
much therapeutically effective as
possible
so that you can you deliver the
minimum amount of virus particles into
the patient's body that you can get away
with
so that is why if you are delivering
some kind of a drug product
which is perhaps just 20 or 25
full capsules and 75 perhaps empty or
maybe
partial then that is a situation where
um you know perhaps you could try to do
better i mean if you could reverse
the ratios and you would end up
delivering something that is 70 or 90
percent
full capital then you wouldn't have that
many
non-bioactive particles being delivered
into the patient's body which might
induce
an allergic response and again it's
important to remember
that the number of particles that you're
introducing into a patient's body
if that number is something like um
there have been some trials in which
i think that number has been 10 uh 11
vital particles per kilogram of body
weight
so uh or even more so you might
end up with a situation where you're
actually delivering
maybe a quadrillion virus particles to a
patient's body and if you're doing that
and
you have an uh adverse allergic reaction
then extremely nasty effects could
happen i mean sepsis could follow and
you might have a really bad outcome and
the point of using
a good quality control experiment to
ensure that you're delivering
as much bioactive particles as possible
and minimizing the allergic response
has extremely visible real life effects
in terms of patient outcomes and
absolutely some things that you should
be doing
over to europe okay great um
so the next question is coming in is
asking at
why is there such a trend um towards
trying to increase the yield of the
viral vector
in these um different productions
increase the yield of the vital factor
um so
it just turns out that making virus
particles is
expensive and um
um if you're react and i actually spoke
to
a virologist some time ago who mentioned
literally whose statement was that
while viral vectors are more expensive
than gold you can get gold if you
pay for it but sometimes you cannot get
viral vector because it is that hard to
make
so yeah it's um whether you're doing
a large scale therapy where you're
trying to treat a lot of people
or whether you're making a therapeutic
attempt which is really on the lines of
personalized medicine you have to get
get the cost down as far as possible
viral vectors
and gene therapy treatment in general
really is at the cutting bleeding edge
of state-of-the-art biotechnology today
this
is really not something which
is available to people in the third
world who do not have the kind of
economic resources
which would allow them to have these
treatments and yet it is also
perhaps one of the most promising
developments in
medicine and biotechnology in the last
three decades
so it is incumbent upon us to make every
effort possible
to bring the costs down so that this
kind of treatment
might be more widely available and of
course the first
step in bringing these costs down is to
actually make
more bioactive bio vector particles
and in that context the effort by joshi
and co-workers
in this head batch schematic design is
really great because
they got this amazing increase of
density of the producer cells they also
got
an increase in the number of viral
concentration of viral genomes
and best of all turns out from their
analysis
that the viral particles that they are
making with the fed back system
are as active as you would make with the
conventional
low density system and they also have
the same packing traction more or less
so that's really great right
um so as kind of a follow-up to what you
just mentioned with the
yoshi paper there's someone asking for a
little bit more detail
on what a fed batch process looks like
okay so uh you know what we'll do uh
we'll
send uh when we send out our follow-up
email uh we'll send a link to that paper
i believe it is freely available for
download
so you'll find all of the details that
you need about um
density at the point of infection and
exactly what kind of nutrients were put
in
and what kind of process this monitoring
system was available
uh yeah we'll just send you the link to
the paper
okay perfect um so another question is a
little bit more of a situational example
but this person says
i'm trying to set up a binding isotherm
series of experiments to determine kd
for my protein
but i'm not able to reach the low
concentration range that i need to
access
because there's not enough signal what
can i do
okay excellent question i mean if you're
trying to set up a binding isotherm
then i mean you know that if you're
doing a proper binding isotherm you at
least need to be one order of magnitude
above and one
order below of the kd in you know
otherwise your random isotherm
um in the logarithmic scale just won't
look like a proper s-shaped curve
um and results won't be reliable so this
is what you do
you have the advantage of picking the
detection wavelength
of interest so if you have a
system where you're looking at the
absorption
280 nanometers which of course comes
from your thyroid superfine
side chains of proteins and you see that
you just don't have
enough signal coming out of there when
you're going to lower concentrations
then you should consider switching over
to detecting the peptide bond itself and
230 nanometers is a great wavelength to
use because
it's kind of close to where the peptide
bond is although not exactly
and at the same time it responds to a
fairly bright peak
on the xenon flash lamp which is the
light source for the optima ac
and that will allow you to access the
lower concentration
values of course i strongly suggest that
you do a bunch of uv-vis
measurements on a cuvette to make sure
that you're able to correlate the 280
and the 230 nanometer measurements in
order to
you know establish linearity in your
dilution series
and uh correspondingly if you have to go
to higher concentrations
then just start measuring off of the 280
nanometer
peak i mean measured at 290 for example
but the extinction coefficient is going
to be lower over there
okay good feedback um next question is
is there any experimental situation
where equilibrium gives
more information than velocity for auc
ah that's a good one so
so here's the thing equilibrium
actually does not give you the shape
information
that a velocity experiment does because
it is and
i mean ultimately lots of diffusion
information
uh because diffusion and uh
constitutional source have actually
balanced each other out and everything
is
in equilibrium so
what you do get is the ability to get
molecular weights out of the system with
really great accuracy in fact the most
accuracy that you can in a usb
experiment
but there's something else there are
certain systems
for which uh you could try spinning as
hard as you
can go which is 60 000 rpm as fast as
you can spin
and you really won't get good quality
sedimentation data in fact
at the end all you might end up getting
is a
exponential um looking curve and that
just tells you that there are certain
things which
are going to be better analyzed via
equilibrium experience
experiments in a really small pet type
for example
okay thank you so uh yeah so another is
a
relatively short question but how much
uh aav
sample might you need for this okay
so um this is what you're gonna have to
do
uh you're gonna have to convert your
particle count which is you probably
have something in
you know 10 e 12 or 10 e 13 particles
per ml
that may be your concentration in the
stock tube that you have
you're going to have to convert that to
an absorbance number
and you're going to have to measure the
absorbance at 280 and at 230 nanometers
so if you're doing
an absorption experiment um absorption
detector ac experiment and you
choose to detect that 230 nanometers you
would like to have
maybe 0.7.8 absorption
units at that wavelength and remember
this is with respect to
a one centimeter or a ten millimeter
pass length
so just do the conversion and that's the
concentration that you need and
regarding how much you need
for a typical ac experiment you would
want to have maybe 400
to 450 microliters worth of samples
okay sounds good the next question is
asking about comparing and contrasting a
bit sec
malls which provides molar mass
information
compared to auc can you speak to that
gosh
so seconds is uh i mean it's a really
great technique it's a complementary
technique to auc
and you get really good uh information
regarding molar masses
the thing is that auc is pretty much
unparalleled in its dynamic range i mean
auc is probably the only technique
which will give you an accurate
estimation of molar masses
of systems ranging from the size of a
single peptide
all the way to an intact virus so you
know something
maybe like a hundred thousand all the
way up to the tens of mega dozen
so five ish orders of magnitude
i don't think there are very many
techniques out there which give you that
kind of dynamic range
that being said the caveat of course is
that i'm not necessarily saying that you
will get that information in a single
experiment although there are people
who've designed
extremely clever multi-speed experiments
in which even that is possible
but yes auc does offer you an enormous
dynamic range in terms of measurement
which i don't produce technology can
actually act
okay thank you akash it looks like we
have time for one more
question um so this is a higher level
question related to our current
state of the world um what do you see as
the role of gene therapy or viral
vectors
for covid19 response
ah and again a very interesting question
so i think there are some
vaccine trials which are currently
ongoing
which use
gene therapy based system or
in general adenovirus or aav based
systems so
i i i'm speculating just a little bit
over here
but one of the um ideas
behind building a vaccine
is that you introduce some kind of
a viral particle into the patient's body
and the viral particle has
the spike engineered upon its surface
which are actually related to
the spikes of the disease-causing
virus that you're trying to vaccinate
again
so in other words you have a
basic viral capsid but that basic viral
capsid
is actually presenting um cars cove to
spike so which is why understanding uh
what the stylescope 2 spikes
look like is actually super important
and so the virus that you are developing
has what you might think of if as a
viral
chassis and then these decorations upon
its surface
which are actually engineered to induce
an immune response which is basically
going
to give you antibodies and therefore
vaccinated and
one of the chassis or viral chassis if
you want to use that word
which is used for this purpose is
actually adenovirus
so it's definitely a system which uh
um science used in both gene therapy as
well as in
vaccines
yes absolutely there's a definitely a
lot of crossover and you know in terms
of what you know
vectors are being used for gene therapy
and vaccines for covet and others as
as you mentioned um so again akash thank
you
uh for taking the time to discuss um
virus characterization
i'd also like to thank lavrutz and our
sponsor beckman cultural life sciences
before we go i'd finally like to thank
the audience for joining us today
and participating with all these great
questions there are a number that we
didn't have time to get to today
and those submitted also during
on-demand will be addressed by the
speaker akash
via the contact information that was
provided at the time of registration
when the webinar is recording is
available for replay
you will receive an email from labyrinth
and i encourage you to share that
recording with any colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
i hope to see you again at our upcoming
webinars and until then
take care thank you everyone